allez allez allez allez
on a passé le plan au refuge cinq fois
j'ai la marchandise c'est ça qui compte
non
attrape le câble
[Musique]
d'où il s'agit là de la fameuse équipe
donc on me parle tant les clones
renégats qui fuient l'Empire bonjour que
c'est excitant
l'Empire se renforce toujours en jour
nous devons continuer à nous battre
vous souhaitez être libre à nouveau
ramenez-nous ce trésor de guerre et vous
aurez les moyens de disparaître
la rumeur prétend énormément de clones
résistaient à l'Ordre 66 alors ce sont
des traîtres comme les Jedi
à tout nous avons fait le bon choix
Omega mais il y a d'autres peuples qui
ont aussi besoin de nous
quel est donc cette très triste
n'avancez pas
[Musique]
l'Empire souhaite instaurer l'ordre et
la paix dans toute la galaxie la paix la
paix n'avait jamais été une option
mais des soldats ont fait ce qui doit
être fait en avant as-tu déjà pensé à la
différence entre nous etroïdes nos
décisions nous appartiennent
qu'est-ce qu'il te faut Rex est-ce que
j'aurai une chance de bénéficier de
votre expertise pour une vision